hello I'm sorry aunty
I'm with finally back together it's been
a really long time and we're actually
back with a game that is supposed to be
super scary I did not realize this one
steam
it's called haunted memories it's from
Ned man theory games came out in
September of last year and it's actually
episodic so they've got about six
episodes that are coming out the next
one's coming out on the 30th of January
so right now we only got a pisode one
I'm to understand this is slender is
like oh I can move how much you use by
himself why are the shadows kind of like
that view distance keep something
changed yeah if you do have a PC that's
a bit like tougher than a game this game
really nice and not Brenda at distances
of 10 meters I was just thinking the
same thing pulps I said hopefully
Slenderman doesn't like render when it's
too late it's like when the world is
like in in peril it will be up to one
aesthetic man so what's the point of
there being a map because oh it's not
hello honey try talking to her she is
hey is this lady is this a mistake lady
if the guy comes a minim offer you up as
a sacrifice man I love how you our
updates thank God for Google Maps right
yeah I was gonna say that this is a
paper map I'm gonna find the cage of the
in now are you kidding
how am I gonna find the caver in a
forest I know that is literally
needle-in-a-haystack time I want to get
program wait if it's a guess why meet me
at the what can you say that again
shut the [ __ ] up Jesus Jesus will save
us no reason we're gonna rain McKeen
what do you mean you got the key
I'm assuming you could have unlocked no
no no it was just a gate behind me I had
to restrict C key what is that all
restrict singing hey cool Jessica what
is wrong with you
they've already dropped like $2 get the
aesthetic for appeal
man oh wait there's a note on the wall
and a tripod oh I'm doing [ __ ] baby
it's okay look at this big room it's so
lush Wow this space here north
we'll be safe for me okay okay business
I'm going legitimately insane
I just growled
indigestion causing you trouble ready
damn I hate with him it really makes me
die if you wanna play it's called
haunted memories you can get the first
episode for free on Steam I think it's
also one more DB and indeed it is but
thanks for tuning in again be sure to
leave us your comments and thoughts and
suggestions for horror games to play in
science
buy their own game spot or YouTube and
you can use our HOH live hashtag on
Twitter if you so are inclined next week
is Australia Day I'll probably call it a
hero Stratos so we will be not here in
the office but the house of horrors will
still be on so be sure to tune in then
and we hope you enjoy the show yeah bye
everyone thank you
oh shoot